>>So my question is this, why do
we assume that kids' socializing
and play is not a side of learning?
And on the flip side,
why do we assume
that schools can't have a
spirit of entertainment and play
as part of what they're doing?
>>Last year I wrapped up a
three-year study with a large team
of researchers where we were looking
at a lot of different examples
of kids' new-media
practice, ranging from sort
of everyday hanging-out behavior
on sites like Myspace and Facebook
with text messaging, IM to what we
were calling more "geeked-out" kinds
of participation, like making
YouTube videos, remixing videos,
creating podcasts,
engaging in fan fiction,
and other forms of fan production.
>>I think our most important
top-level finding was
that there was tremendous diversity
in what kids were doing online
and what kids were learning online.
So most kids were engaged
with what we were calling
"friendship-driven participation,"
which was primarily about hanging
out with their friends online.
And this is stuff that's
not so different
from what older generations did
or what kids are doing today
in the lunchroom and
hallways at school.
And this is a really
important side of learning,
the sort of important social
behaviors and what it means to grow
up in a digital world and the sort
of ways in which kids post, link,
forward, comment, create
top-friends lists.
These are all negotiations
that are incredibly important
to kids growing up today.
There was a smaller minority of kids
who started using this baseline
technical and media literacy
as a jumping-off point to start
developing more sophisticated kinds
of skills, and this is what we called
"messing around" or as a transition
to more geeking-out kinds
of forms of participation.
And that's where we saw a
much smaller cut of kids.
It was really a minority, those
kids that tend to be identified
with more creative or geeky or
intellectual pursuits at school,
kids who have strong interest-driven
orientations, and these are the kids
who are using the online world,
using new media-production tools,
games as environments to really
develop specialized interests
and very sophisticated forms of
technical and media literacy.
>>So I think there's this question
about how we look at the relationship
between the friendship-driven
sites or the hanging-out space,
the messing around
and the geeking out.
And I think it's actually important
to value all those activities,
but the way we as parents
and as educators approach
these different kinds
of participation is
very different, I think.
So overall, we found that
kids aren't really welcoming
of adult intervention in
the friendship-driven space.
I mean, I got so many
questions from parents
who were wondering they should
friend their teenage daughter or son
on Facebook, for example, or were
worried about the peer interactions,
and adults have a particular
and complicated role
to kids' peer relations, and
it's actually profoundly creepy
for grown-ups to be participating in
a space where there's a lot of sort
of dating and flirting going around.
So for the most part, adults
are not welcome in that space,
but there is a role for education
in the sense that kids need
to start thinking critically
about things like privacy
and identity and all those things.
And I think the adult world is quite
aware of those concerns and issues
and we've rehashed those quite a lot.
I think the piece that we don't
currently have real awareness
that is shared or broad-based about
is how we support kids' engagement
in the more messing-around
and geeking-out space.
And this is space that
really has the opportunity
to foster kids' intellectual
development, their civic engagement,
their personal development
in really important ways,
and yet we haven't really
worked as educators or parents
to proactively engage kids.
>>There really is a gap in perception
and understanding between generations
about the value of engagement
with online activities.
And so in the adult world,
there was a general perception
that when kids are in front
of the screen or messing
around with their computer,
that it's a waste of time,
that it's taking away from
more productive activities,
healthier activities, whereas
kids ascribe much more value
to those activities.
And that's, in a way, not
so different from, you know,
an earlier generation trying to get
your teenage daughter off the phone
or trying to get your son to come
in from playing with their friends
to focus on their homework,
but I think there's a more
general perception in the culture
around new media that is
associated with entertainment media
and other forms of
just mediated activity
that it is inherently a space
that is hostile to learning.
And that's the perception that I
think we really need to work against.
And part of it is understanding
the differences
between different kinds
of online activities.
So friendship-driven
activities are very different
from interest-driven activity,
and if you lump them all together,
you're actually missing the
opportunity for learning that's
in the space and also
not recognizing the sort
of baseline social learning that's
happening in the friendship space.
>>We know that the learning outside
of school matters tremendously
for the learning in school.
So a lot of what we're trying to
say about kids' informal learning
with new media is part of an already
existing set of understandings
that educators have of the
importance of the home environment,
for the peer environment,
for the community
for learning that happens in schools.
The question is, how
can we be more active
about linking those two together?
>>And I think this is a
tremendous challenge that a lot
of these experimental
efforts are dealing with.
I think for teachers and
schools and classroom learning,
there's still an incredibly
important role to play,
which is about giving kids access
across the board to a baseline set
of standards, literacies,
expectations about what they need
to participate in contemporary
society, to be reflective,
and to also take opportunity of
the fact that you really have kids
and adults in a shared space
that's safe, that's sanctioned,
that gives kids an
opportunity to reflect on things
in their everyday life
that's not just
about them being immersed
in it all the time.
So I think that there are incredibly
important functions for schools.
What we're saying by evaluating
informal learning is not
that we should abandon
formal learning
but that we should get
those working together
in a much more coordinated way.